[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Одеса,
Причорномор'я]
Одеса — це друге найнезабутніше місто в Україні,
тому що тут знаходяться три порти,
дуже багато великих вантажних авто тут проїжджають,
і в повітрі дуже багато важких металів.
Наше завдання, щоб дуже багато людей зрозуміло,
що таке електричний транспорт, як ним користуватися,
які в нього є переваги.
І наші амбіції:
якомога більше людей перевести,
[Сергій Вельчев,
засновник EcoFactor]
як ми кажемо, на «світлу сторону»,
щоб вони пересувалися за допомогою електричної тяги.
Як кажуть, все в Одесі робиться на Молдаванці на Малій Арнаутській вулиці.
Ми знаходимося на Молдаванці — напівпідвальне приміщення,
одна з маленьких лабораторій, яка є — це наша.
Все, що ми виготовляємо,
народжується тут в голові,
потім тут воно народжується в схемах,
потім в «залізі»
І ми, якось так, поступово розвиваємось.
Мій дід був одним з перших фермерів у Одеській області,
і коли Радянський Союз розвалився,
почалися приватизації і все таке інше.
Була можливість відкрити в 91-му році фермерське господарство.
Потім до цього, з часом, підключився мій батько —
він є фермером.
Я так зрозумів, що я теж колись буду фермером,
я про це вам вчора казав,
що я хочу бути таким фермером,
який керує автопілотними тракторами,
які ще там виробляють,
програму якусь зробив, вони все це роблять,
ти просто на електричному літаку літаєш,
бачиш поля, як вони ростуть,
все це контролюєш датчиками.
І я зрозумів, що технологічно це вже можливо.
Просто інертно ніхто до цього не йде.
Є технології, які треба просто з'єднати і воно буде працювати,
але це дуже довго.
І я зрозумів,
що мені треба щось таке зробити для сільського господарства.
Тут знаходиться акумуляторна батарея,
зараз я можу відкрити, показати.
Якщо ви побачите.
На базі Харківського тракторного заводу,
раніше він називався Т-25,
зараз він, здається, ХТЗ-3211.
Все це є — акумуляторний блок.
Двигуна тут немає.
Двигун знаходиться десь тут.
У нього повітряне охолодження. І все.
Більше нічого тут немає.
Достатньо, щоб тут було три передачі.
У звичайного трактора десь шість,
ще є нижча передача, вища передача,
загалом десь, здається, 18 передач.
Тут достатньо три, для того, щоб він працював.
Ця станція може заряджати,
у залежності від того, який зарядний пристрій в машині,
від трьох до семи кіловат
чи до 22-х, якщо це машина європейського зразка.
Ця станція може заряджати 50 кіловат напряму в батарею,
незважаючи на те,
який бортовий зарядний пристрій стоїть у машині,
тобто вона оминає зарядний пристрій,
який конвертує змінний струм у постійний струм,
і напряму в батарею її заряджає.
Як це відбувається:
людина підходить,
вмикає зарядний пристрій на зарядку,
вмикає в машину,
підходить, авторизується карткою
чи через додаток,
вона запускається, а людина пішла собі, відпочиває.
Це було хобі, і це хобі стало бізнесом.
Україна є в десятці країн,
які розвиваються дуже гарними темпами
у галузі електромобілів.
І все це відбувається за рахунок ентузіастів,
які щось хочуть зробити.
І це дало такий поштовх потужний
що ми є конкуретними на західних ринках.
Великий поштовх дав «постмайданний період»:
люди почали розуміти, що щось треба робити,
щось треба змінювати, якось треба рухатись.
В українців це десь в крові:
незалежність, яка має бути, волелюбність.
І електричний транспорт — це така можливість.
Ти можеш поставити сонячні панелі на даху,
заряджатися від Сонця і нікому не сплачувати.
Є велика економічна мотивація.
І це поступово якось дало такий поштовх.
Якщо два-три роки тому мені потрібно було доводити,
що електричний транспорт — це круто
це екологічно, це майбутнє,
то зараз достатньо просто сказати, що воно є,
сказати скільки це коштує,
і людина буде думати чи зможе вона собі це дозволити, чи ні.
І ось так от якось відбувається.
Це Тесла, яка пішла на запчастини,
а це Тесла, яка піде на запчастини.
Там Тесла, яку ми зараз ремонтуємо.
Це — старий електричний Citroen.
Це наш проєкт:
ми робили вантажний Nissan Leaf
для комерційних цілей.
Тобто Nissan Leaf із заводу такий не випускається,
ми зробили вантажну платформу і протестували.
Тут багато всього,
і ось він наш Запорожець.
Стоїть тут, сумує.
Ми на ньому брали участь у двох заходах.
Перший захід, до якого ми його, власне, готували —
це ми їздили в рейс Київ — Монако.
Було раллі. Ми проїхали на ньому 3,5 тис. км.
На одній зарядці він проїхав від Одеси до Києва,
і далі — у Бучу.
Тобто він проїжджав на одній зарядці понад 500 км,
у залежності від режиму їзди.
Ми посіли друге місце.
Це була дуже цікава пригода,
де ми всіх дивували, всім все подобалось.
І Запорожець впорався зі своєю задачею,
ми його дуже швидко зробили: протягом місяця.
Його задачею було привертати увагу,
і показати, що електротранспорт — це вже теперішнє.
Чому ми вибрали саме Запорожець?
Щоб показати, що Україна може бути іноваційною,
тобто зовнішність — стара,
яка наповнена новим змістом,
більш іноваційним.
Він із цією задачею впорався на всі 100 відсотків.
Зараз у нього буде інша задача:
ми плануємо його зробити дуже швидким,
а зовнішньо він залишиться таким самим.
Машини, які будуть, умовно, стояти десь поруч на світлофорі,
відчують усю привабливість електричної тяги.
Дуже багато є цікавих проєктів,
але все має іти крок за кроком.
Мотивацією не є просто щось робити,
а мотивацією є робити те, чого ніхто не робив,
для того, щоб якось рухатися, розвиватися,
і показати, що ми можемо, ми здатні.
Не можна жалітися на те, що якісь умови не ті, чи ще щось не те.
Якщо хочеш щось зробити — треба просто взяти і робити.
Може виходити не з першого разу,
може виходити не так, як хотілося,
не так, як планувалося, не в той час.
Але треба робити.
Якщо ти дійсно цього хочеш — треба просто взяти і робити.
[Автор проекту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олег Марчук]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Монтажерка
Юлія Рублевська]
[Субтитрувальниця
Оля Стулій]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]